bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi 9
septembre bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une nouvelle
émission durant laquelle nous allons
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres les policiers
municipaux de mort pas entraînés aux
pratiques du self défense plusieurs
agents ont été formés pendant trois
jours objectif mieux sécuriser les
interventions elle durait dure la crise
dans le monde agricole entre baisse des
prix inondations et sécheresses pour
tenter d'y répondre la région
ile-de-france a annoncé le déblocage
d'une aide exceptionnelle nous en
parlerons avec notre invité un céréalier
yvelinois et puis dans cette émission
nous reviendrons sur le reste de
l'actualité avec notamment nicolas
sarkozy en déplacement à poissy ou
encore la rentrée scolaire mais
l'actualité la plus récente c'est la
primaire de la droite et du centre les
candidats avaient jusqu'au 9 septembre
pour déposer leur candidature les noms
des participants officiels à la primaire
seront connus le 21 septembre prochain
dans les yvelines trois candidats
espérer faire partie de la course c'est
bon pour jean frédéric poisson député de
la 10e circonscription des yvelines et
président du parti chrétien démocrate
ils n'étaient pas soumis aux règles du
parrainage ça coince en revanche pour
jacques milliards le député-maire de
maisons-laffitte il n'y a pas réussi
notamment à rassembler un nombre
suffisant de parlementaires sur sa
candidature quant à henri guaino le
député yves binois il a annoncé qu'il se
présenterait directement à la l'élection
présidentielle sans passer par la case
primaire l'ancienne plume de nicolas
sarkozy a déclaré ne pas vouloir rester
les bras croisés devant un tel naufrage
fin de citation dans le reste de
l'actualité à saint quentin après la
signature d'une convention de
coordination entre la police municipale
de maurepas et la police ministre
national en juin dernier agents
municipaux et de surveillance de la
voirie ont été formés aux pratiques du
self défense un reportage de corinne
falun
elle dégage et je parviens
maîtrise de soi gestion du stress et
surtout communication autant de notions
essentielles pour sécuriser les
interventions des policiers municipaux
pendant trois jours au parc des sports
du bout des clots de maurepas ils ont
été formés au self défense et à son
cadre légal
l'intérêt pour les policiers municipaux
ne mord pas de suivre cette formation
c'est de leur garantir
d'intervenir pour en toute sécurité mais
également pour autrui tout en respectant
les droits fondamentaux de la personne
bien sûr les agents de surveillance de
la voie publique non autorisée à porter
des armes étaient eux aussi intégré à la
formation pour être formés aux
techniques de maîtrise d'individus
depuis deux ans la ville de maurepas a
choisi de renforcer sa police municipale
en quadruplant son effectif passant de
deux à huit agents suite à une la
signature d'une convention coordination
nous avons demandé l'autorisation en
préfecture de doter notre police
municipale d'armes de catégorie d donc à
savoir des bâtons de défense et des
bombes lacrymogènes pour la catégorie d
il n'y a pas de formation obligatoire
mais nous avons souhaité que les agents
soient formés au maniement de ce
matériel à l'issue de cet apprentissage
le formateur fera passer aux agents un
test d'aptitude une demande de porc
individuelles seraient ensuite rédigé au
préfet sous réserve d'un avis médical
favorable
et pour évoquer l'actualité de la
semaine maintenant un invité sur notre
plateau olivier brousseau bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes s'est rallié aux élus
et le roi dans les yvelines et membre de
la fnsea fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles on va
évoquer avec vous bien sûr la crise du
monde agricole qui n'en finit plus les
producteurs de lait fin août
les éleveurs bovins à cette semaine
dites nous un peu est-ce que cette crise
va-t-elle terminer un jour va-t-elle
s'arrêter selon vous aussi vous êtes
optimiste quand vous voyez toute
l'actualité qui touchent votre mandat
vous et là j'ai plutôt un message assez
pessimiste parce que la crise nos amis
les éleveurs sont dedans depuis quatre
ans nous s'est rallié cette année on
fait une année noire comme on n'a jamais
connu depuis que je me suis installé
mois en 89 on a eu l'année 2002 de
mémoire il y avait également l'année
1976 où il y avait eu les poses
sécheresse mais là c'est encore plus
grave que l'année 1976 donc on n'avait
pas à vouloir demander un
impôt-sécheresse rassurez vous mais là
c'est plutôt inverse ont eu un excès de
au mois de mai juin avec un manque
d'ensoleillement ce qui a fait des trois
mauvaises fréquentations au niveau de la
floraison du blé mal de toutes les
cultures et on a fait des rendements
comme on l'a jamais fait c'est enfin
c'est hélas on a battu des records très
bien ça donne l'impression que ce soit
les éleveurs les producteurs
il ya toujours une crise on a
l'impression tous les ans tous les deux
trois ans un nouveau mouvement qui se
met en place une crise des solutions qui
sont apportées par les par les pouvoirs
publics mais finalement ça recommence en
commune comme une musique sans fin
comment ça se fait ça c'est dire qu'il
ya pas de solution pour le très long
terme ce qui se passe c'est que faut
revenir justement en arrière avant on
avait la pac qui nous protégeait
maintenant on est en cours mondial il ya
eu aucune en filet de sécurité il n'y a
rien qui nous protège donc en france on
a on a des charges franco françaises qui
sont très très lourde et par rapport à
une économie agricole mondiale donc
comme vous savez qu'un
un employé
de pologne touche 15 euros par jour
alors que nous c'est bientôt à leur ouïe
qu'on lui même pas compétitif au sein de
l'europe donc justement sur cette
question de la problématique quel est le
problème principal aujourd'hui c'est une
question de prix c'est une question de
charge est ce que c'est les banques qui
jouent pas le jeu quel est le trop de
charges pour vous quels étaient les
problèmes principal s'il y avait un
problème principal c'est non de
concurrence de compétitivité comme on
essaie on a on a trop de charges vous
dit on on paye des taxes de tous les
côtés on doit se mettre aux normes c'est
ça nous coûte énormément cher on n'a pas
les moyens justement de faire tout ça et
en plus cette année je vous dis on a il
ya eu trois facteurs qui se cumulent
déjà donc le climat qui n'a pas être du
tout été favorables ce qui a fait qu'on
a fait des rendements divisé par deux
mais a malgré tout au plus le peu de
céréales qu'on a récolté la qualité a
été catastrophique on a même des
pénalités par rapport à notre qualité et
en plus de chance pour nous vous avez
par contre en ukraine et en amérique du
nord nos concurrents exportateur de
céréales ils ont fait une bonne année
cette année donc quand vous cumulez les
trois on est mort donc a heureusement
qu'il ya ya comme les banques qui nous
soutiennent on peut remercier aussi
valérie pécresse qui nous a fait un
geste symbolique mais malgré tout qui
est déjà un début s'amorce un peu la
pompe en espérant que les instances
politiques ou même les départements les
intercommunalités quelqu'un ne vous
adaptiez parce qu on a offert un appel
au peuple à pouvoir écrire à sauver nos
exploitations on va on va évoquer le cas
de valérie pécresse et de l'aide qu'elle
débloque pour vous soutenir mais sur
votre cas vous en particulier ses pairs
dont vous parliez à cause des
inondations au mois de mai au mois de
juin et puis de la sécheresse de cette
fin d'été
combien ça représente en termes de
pertes en termes de pourcentages
peut-être surtout ce que vous produisez
d'habitude mais là bas cette année pour
vous expliquer moi j'ai travaillé pour
perdre de l'argent j'en suis on a perdu
globalement entre 4 et 500 euros de
l'hectare on ne sait pas encore
exactement s'ils ont les prix de nos
céréales parce que là on n'a pas encore
touché de lacs ou de toucher un acompte
mais on ne sait pas exactement ce qui
vous me payez pas ce que l'on va avoir
énormément de réactions je pense que là
ça va plutôt être dans les 500 euros de
l'hectare de pertes ce qui veut dire que
moi je vais perdre de 120000 euros cette
année pour avoir travaillé comme c'est
complètement des marlies alors j'espère
que les banques là on a un appel de
trésorerie énorme parce que on va avoir
du mal à payer nos fournisseurs
là dès le mois de décembre ça va être
très compliqué de parce que notre future
école c'est qu'au moins deux mois d'août
julia août 2017 et on va voir si moi
très difficile on va être dans le rouge
tout ce que cette situation s'est
principalement les céréaliers dans les
yvelines ou alors c'est c'est tous les
agriculteurs c'est tout le monde
agricole qui est touché ou est-ce qu'il
y en a qui sont finalement
le problème justement la dégradation au
niveau de la pifométrie elle s'est
centrée surtout sur bassin parisien le
plus touché c'est le sud essonne et
loiret mais après vous reprenez même la
champagne ça remonte dans l'oise et dont
les yvelines val d'oise on va chercher
dans l'eure l'eure-et-loir ouais tout le
bassin parisien qui a été touché
énormément quoi et pour répondre à cette
crise les pouvoirs publics essaient de
trouver des solutions et il y a quelques
jours valérie pécresse présidente de la
région ile de france s'est rendu dans
une exploitation hesdinoise après les
aléas climatiques du printemps et de cet
été de nombreuses structures
franciliennes ont vu leurs récoltes
fortement diminué un reportage de
mélanie potée
de 500 à 600 euros par hectare des
pertes catastrophiques selon les
agriculteurs franciliens la récolte 2016
et inédite mercredi 31 août la
présidente de la région ile de france a
présenté un dispositif de soutien de
plus de 6 millions d'euros il faut être
à leurs côtés il faut les aider il faut
être là et la mesure qui nous ont
proposés
est une mesure intelligente parce que
l'idée c'est d'éviter l'effet domino
aujourd'hui ils ont créé mauvaise
récolte 6 m les mauvaises graines qu'ils
ont récolté cette année ils ont une
récolte encore pire donc on va
travailler sur la qualité des semences
on va aider à acheter des bonnes
semences pour que la récolte soit
meilleur l'année prochaine les grains de
blé porte les stigmates des mauvaises
conditions climatiques de ces derniers
mois moins coloré plus petit la récolte
de lucien va les céréaliers yvelinois a
été fortement touchée lors de la moisson
en récoltant le grain on s'est aperçu
que les épines étaient formés mais qui
avait rien dedans c'est à dire en
épluchant
un épi de blé on s'est retrouvé avec 4 5
grains normaux et tout le reste des
petits grains ou ratatiner
malade une année normale en blé jeu
je suis en une moyenne de 80 85 quintaux
et
là je me retrouve
sur un rendement de 40 40 quintaux les
plus anciens d'entre nous nos parents
nos grands parents n'ont jamais connu
cette situation il était resté gravé
l'année 76 dans les mémoires qui était
une année de sécheresse celle ci qui
avait un pacte et durement les
rendements mais une année 2016 comme ça
qui impacte avec des niveaux de
rendement
/ 2d chiffre d'affaires divisé par deux
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais
connu le dispositif actuel s'ajoutent
aux millions d'euros déjà débloqués par
la région en soutien aux agriculteurs
touchés par les inondations
olivier brousseau la région qui débloque
plus de six millions d'euros pour vous
j'imagine que c'est une nouvelle qui
doit vous ravir est ce que c'est c'est
suffisant pour autant une telle somme
alors il faudrait beaucoup plus pour
vous expliquer remercie jeudi valérie
pécresse qui vient justement nous aider
un petit peu c'est très symbolique parce
que ces symboles un petit peu de nous
aider sert des semences c'est ce
anticipe la future école 2017 pour
éviter justement l'effet boule de neige
par contre
ce qu'elle nous donne c'est ça
représente pour vous expliquer cette
année bruxelles va nous diminue encore
nos z2 de l'europe donc deux par rapport
à ce qu'elle va ce qu'elle va nous
donner ça représente même pas ce que
bruxelles va me soustraire cette année
mais bon c'est déjà ça c'est d'un côté
on nous donne et de coton pourquoi nous
on a un peu la politique des porte
monnaie qui circulent on entendait dans
le reportage le parallèle avec l'année
76 est ce que cette année 2016 est la
pire que vous vous ayez connue et que
les agriculteurs vous connaissez est
connu aussi un nez complètement puisque
en 76 les agriculteurs avaient beaucoup
moins de charges ils étaient pas il
n'était pas étrangler comme nous avec la
fiscalité avec les mises aux normes
comme nous avons maintenant actuellement
c'est pour ça qu'on demande une année
blanche au niveau de remboursement
d'emprunt on demande justement l'arrêt
des contraintes justement
administratives et de mise aux normes
parce que on pourra pas du tout arriver
à répondre à tout le monde et une année
comme celle ci est ce que pour vous
malheureusement est-ce qu'il va falloir
s'y habituer ou alors il reste tout de
même exceptionnel est ce que vous avez
peur de devoir vous y habituer dans
notre métier on est habitué à avoir des
mauvaises années donc l'espoir fait
vivre on a et ce qui va se passer s'il
va nous falloir au moins quatre à cinq
ans d'année correct pour éponger cette
année parce que ça nous fait un trou
énorme et non au niveau trésorerie s'est
envoyé à même les jeunes là certains
agriculteurs qui vont être obligés de
jeter les poules quoi justement en terme
de météo va rentrer dans l'automne d'ici
quelques jours qu'elle serait la météo
parfaite pour vous qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour essayer de remonter
un peu la pente comme vous le dites en
plus cette année là on est déjà en train
de semer le colza pour la future récolte
là après la l'excès de pluie au mois de
mai juin maintenant on se retrouve en
situation de sécheresse calamiteuse
puisque nous avons encore les mecs à
récolter les betteraves ça c'est des
cultures qui sont en place ils auraient
eu besoin d'eau ces jours ci les eaux
n'ont pas reçus donc finalement on va
même pas pouvoir se rattraper sur notre
culture le poème de cette année c'est
que toutes les cultures vont être
impactés du début jusqu'à la fin et on
est en train de rater nos semis pour la
la future récolte avec cette sécheresse
doc également on espère avoir de l'eau
mais notre niveau notre méthode nous en
annonce pas du tout avant qu'un jour mon
tant mieux pour lui pour les touristes
mais il ya beaucoup de conneries ce mois
de septembre les annonces des 31 32
degrés la semaine prochaine pour nous
c'est une catastrophe on reste dans la
thématique agricole avec la crise des
producteurs de lait cette fois ci pour y
répondre des fermes et binoy se sont
associés produisent dorénavant le lait
est d'ile-de-france une démarche locale
et éco-responsable un reportage de
florane parfait ils en sont très fiers
seul et d'île de france c'est le leur
c'est aussi une aventure inédite
intermarché s'est associé avec trois
fermes yvelinoise vite à jouy en josas
la ferme de bissy abonnés les la ferme
de tilleur regret ni pour distribuer et
produire le lait d'île de france sacrée
aussi je dirais une valeur ajoutée sur
l'anglais de façon à ce que nos
entreprises puissent vivre continuer à
gagner de l'argent pour continuer à
investir les voir continuer à se
développer dans espère retrouver déjà un
souffle de trésorerie 1 clairement et
puis bah c'est faire connaître
notre ferme notre production or notre et
nos fermes d'ailleurs ce qu'on raisonne
collectivement avec bulletins et voilà
faire connaître aux consommateurs qui
une ferme qui peuvent venir ici visiter
la ferme en chiffres le lait
d'ile-de-france ses 1200 vaches sur
trois ferme et 10 millions de litres par
an vendu 80 centimes la brique il est
collectée est conditionnée par la
laiterie saint denis de l'hôtel situé
dans le loiret le cinquième partenaire
on a l'assurance que le produit va être
mis dans les magasins va être valorisée
ensuite c'est à nous d'aller expliquer
aux consommateurs pourquoi ce produit là
eh bien il a de l'intérêt pour lui en
termes de qualité produit en terme de
deux prix en termes ensuite de
revalorisation au niveau 2 au niveau des
des producteurs de lait et c'est tout
l'enjeu que l'on a aujourd'hui une
tentative de réponse à la crise du lait
cette brique est distribué dans 2 137
magasins en ile de france initié par
intermarché le partenariat vise à
développer une nouvelle filière
régionale d'approvisionnement mais aussi
de mettre en valeur ces fermes beaucoup
de clients déjà ça froid qui avait ferme
dans 78 qui font du lait ça c'est
important de le savoir ensuite ce sont
des fermes qui sont ouvertes au public
donc aujourd'hui le consommateur qui va
être et qui va être curieux va pouvoir
aller les visiter pourquoi pas et
aujourd'hui la qualité du lait qu'on
vend est irréprochable donc on est très
à l'aise sur le sujet le lait
d'ile-de-france est exclusivement vendu
par les mousquetaires jusqu'au 30
septembre par la suite ils pourraient
être commercialisés par d'autres
enseignes sur la première année pas
moins de 23 mille briques de lait
attendons pour une future dégustation
olive et gossau quel regard vous portez
sur cette initiative se laissant pour 5
de france est ce que c'est ça la
solution pour pour répondre à la crise
se rassembler pour être plus forts et
puis pour distribuer des produits locaux
du terroir on va dire c'est une très
très bonne initiative
de toute façon la flore diversifiée
chercher des revenus autres que notre
métier de base donc si on peut aller de
la transformation jusqu'à la
commercialisation
c'est vraiment l'idéal ce qui se passe
c'est que bon bah ça va
quand on touche à plusieurs métiers
c'est un peu compliqué à gérer mais par
contre ça va peut-être pouvoir créer
également blancs bush dans l'école est
ce que ça se passe aussi du côté des
consommateurs qui doivent changer leur
façon de consommer tout simplement et
puis d'aller peut-être voir la ferme d'à
côté le producteur local et puis c'est
vrai quand ils le font sur le sait pas
forcément s'étaient dits dans le sujet
mais il ya des producteurs locaux même
si on est en région parisienne pas tout
à fait comme vous le dites en région
parisienne il ya on est encore quatre
mille cinq cents exploitations agricoles
donc on représente quasiment 50% du
territoire faut pas nous oublier c'est
vrai que
l'on fait partie justement du poumon
vert un petit peu de paris il ya un
manque de reconnaissance selon vous
aussi du monde agricole aujourd'hui
votre place dans la société non non je
sais que deux spectacles à la population
est très reconnaissante justement de
elles sont fières justement je vois les
ceux qui habitent dans nos régions sont
contents d'habiter dans un petit village
à 30 km de paris ça c'est sûr que c'est
une chance inespérée donc de ce côté-là
on apporte une qualité de vie qui n'est
pas négligeable après on a des conflits
entre les ruraux les nouveau nés hors
euro mais ça c'est une autre histoire
retour à la politique maintenant avec le
département des yvelines décidément au
coeur de la primaire de la droite et du
centre mardi nicolas sarkozy le
président des républicains tenait un
meeting apprécié entre dédicaces et
tables rondes l'ancien président de la
république n'a jamais évoqué ses soucis
judiciaires reportage
comme si de rien n'était il serre des
mains fédé selphy signe des autographes
nicolas sarkozy était dans les yvelines
pour parler éducation après une table
ronde à orgeval avec des professeurs
d'école il s'est rendu à poissy pour
dédicacer son livre tout pour la france
l'occasion pour l'ancien président de la
république de mesurer le soutien
indéfectible de ses partisans aucun
doute aucun doute je toujours confiance
en lui je soutiendrai jusqu'en 2017 je
veux l'aider enfin on peut tous les
décès et si on rassemble et français où
ils ont peu les livres je vois pas qui
d'autre peut nous sortir de ce guêpier
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui entre les
attentes des attentes à calais le social
qui nous prend un argent monstrueux
aujourd'hui les subventions des communes
qui disparaissent comme
neige qui fond au soleil voilà donc je
pense qu'il a commencé sarkozy oui
aujourd'hui franchement qui peut faire
quelque chose pour la france soutient
également du côté des élus locaux alors
que nicolas sarkozy a vu son agenda
judiciaire se remplir en début de
semaine avec l'annoncé de son éventuel
renvoi devant le tribunal dans l'
affaire des comptes de campagne vous
avez les les comptes de monsieur jospin
n'était pas exacte on le sait maintenant
monsieur dumas raconter c'est le conseil
constitutionnel a préféré regarder
ailleurs ça a été la même chose pour les
comptes de monsieur balladur ment cette
histoire de comptes de campagne ça me
paraît être un péché véniel les gens
font la part des choses faut arrêter de
penser que les gens ne sont pas capables
de voir ne soit pas capable de voir
les énormes ficelles les câbles que
tendent
la majorité actuelle pour entraver la
route d'un homme vers la présidence
calme serein devant une salle acquise à
sa cause le président des républicains a
tenu à rassurer s'il en était encore
besoin ses partisans rien ne l'empêchera
d'être candidat
aucune polémique
aucune manoeuvre
aucune manipulation haution 2 soit elle
ne me détournera d'un centimètre de ma
volonté absolue de construire avec vous
une alternance forte une alternance
franche une alternance perceptible par
tous les français avant la présidence
nicolas sarkozy devra passer par la case
primaire les candidats officiels seront
connus le 9 septembre pour une élection
les 20 et 27 novembre prochains
olivier brousseau les candidats à la
présidentielle vont forcément essayer de
vous séduire al'approche de la
présidentielle justement c'est comme ça
tous les cinq ans à quelle annonce à
quelle mesure vous serez
particulièrement attentif le jour de
faire votre choix
ça va être justement le fait de nous
soutenir savoir qu'est ce qu'ils vont
nous faire par rapport au maintien nous
nos faibles venant de
la diminution de nos charges on en est
là quoi c'est payer payer moins de
charges paris va nous soutenir pour pas
par rapport justement même il faudrait
presque mettre des filets de sécurité
par rapport à la concurrence
internationale ça va se jouer au niveau
mondial jeudi on est plus petite échelle
française là ça va dépendre justement on
espère avoir une europe forte avec
l'alliance de angela merkel qui qui va
qui va arriver peut-être avoir une robe
vraiment très fort parce que
l'agriculture représente justement 70%
de de l'europe à la base
si on n'a pas une culture forte
européenne je sais pas ce qu'est ce
qu'on va devenir l'actualité de la
semaine c'était également la reprise de
l'école pour 80 mille collégiens et 5000
enseignants yvelinois la nouveauté cette
année c'est évidemment la réforme des
collèges elle est contestée depuis des
mois par une partie des syndicats est de
personnaliser développement du numérique
le recteur de l'académie de versailles
s'est rendu au collège de la shoah elle
encourt pour défendre ces nouveautés un
reportage de nicolas d'andry
pour les élèves et les enseignants le
changement c'est pour maintenant avec la
réforme du collège sur fond de
contestation syndicale le recteur de
l'académie de versailles a tenu à
défendre ces transformations notamment
d'ordre pédagogique
l'aide personnalisée qui fait que les
professeurs vont travailler avec les
élèves par groupe soit parce que
certains ont de difficultés soit en
faisant travailler ceux qui ont plus
plus réussi à côté d'autres élèves une
pédagogie aussi par projet à travers les
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire la réforme du collège
apporterait de la progressivité dans
l'évaluation les classes de 5e 4e et 3e
seront penser globalement avec une
adaptation du programme par rapport à
l'évolution des compétences des élèves
chaque année c'est un processus pendant
trois ans pendant lequel les professeurs
doivent s'étaler les acquisitions pas
les répéter chaque année les pensées par
rapport à un objectif c'est ça le grand
changement ces changements facilitera
l'intégration du numérique dans les
collèges une priorité dans l'académie de
versailles avec son plan numérique pour
l'éducation
le recteur a donné un kit composé d'une
tablette d'un rétroprojecteur et d'une
caméra à l'ambassadeur numérique du
collège de l'avion ça me permet de
beaucoup mieux ciblés de beaucoup mieux
différencier
les apprentissages et de personnaliser
mon apprentissage par rapport à chaque
élève tous les élèves de 6e du collège
de l'avion ont reçu une tablette à la
rentrée 24000 ont été prévus pour cette
rentrée dans toute l'académie de
versailles avec un espoir à la clé une
augmentation de la réussite des élèves
tout à l'heure on évoqué la solution des
circuits courts est ce que aussi c'est
une solution que les que les collèges
viennent se fournir directement en
produits locaux est ce que c'est une
pratique qui se fait de plus en plus
c'est ce que c'est une pratique qui va
et qui doit se développer un grand
espoir sur ce domaine là de restauration
dans les écoles ça on a besoin de deux
bouchées de toute façon donc ça c'est un
très grand débouché et c'est vrai qu'on
est tout près de paris c'est dommage par
rapport à la pollution de faire venir de
la marchandise de l'étranger autant
servir des circuits courts ça c'est une
demande très forte de notre de notre
monde agricole mais également c'est la
fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci olivier
brousseau de nous avoir accompagnés
pendant ces demi heure je rappelle que
vous êtes membre de la fnsea et s'y
rallier aux élus et le roi dans les
yvelines merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et bon week-end à tous